Ось такі дрони німці хочуть придбати
для свого Бундесверу.
Heron TP ізраїльського виробництва.
Надсучасний, наднадійний і здатний перевозити ракети.
Спершу Бундесвер планує використовувати дрони
для розвідувальних місій. Але в довгостроковій перспективі
розглядається також можливість і для воєнного застосування.
Бундесвер вже мав можливість випробувати
неозброєну версію Heron TP.
Упродовж десяти років німецькі солдати
отримували за допомогою цих безпілотних літальних апаратів
високоякісні знімки з великої висоти у своїх місіях
в Малі та в Афганістані.
Однак у разі нападу на німецьких солдатів
стара версія дрона не може їх захистити.
І поки підійде допомога з повітря, мине багато дорогоцінного часу.
Тому з'явилася ідея оснастити ці дрони зброєю,
яка б застосовувалася в разі небезпеки для німецьких військовослужбовців,
як це роблять американці.
Однак критики вважають озброєні дрони - знаряддям диявола.
Дослідник миру за освітою, політик від Лівої партії Німеччини
Тобіас Пфлюґер бачить це саме так.
Досвід показує, що дрони частково взагалі
не можуть оцінити ситуацію зі знімків, які вони роблять.
І дуже часто влучають у людей, в яких, власне, не мали влучити.
Тож, питання в тому, чи можна обходитися
з політичними противниками таким чином,
що їх просто страчують.
Тому урядові партії ХДС/ХСС та СДПН
хочуть широкої суспільної дискусії
щодо того, чи можна дозволяти дронам вбивати людей.
Політики від опозиції вважають це лише окозамилюванням.
Тому що, звісно, озброєні дрони
ставатимуть дедалі поширенішим явищем,
бо це крок до автономних збройних систем,
тобто до зброї, де рішення пропонуватиме або й навіть прийматиме комп'ютер.
Тому необхідно негайно врегулювати це питання
на рівні прав людини.
13 червня в Бундестазі обговорюватимуть
моральний аспект цього питання.
З іншого боку, Німеччина не хоче
пасти задніх у питанні збройних технологій.